Um, I try to look friendly, maybe because I've done better, but I enjoy doing it.
Thank you.
You can take a seat.
Oh!
You can take a seat here.
Oh wow, okay!
um you can press play when you're ready and then pause you can pause and press and press
this one too okay oh my gosh
yeah I'm pretty much losing my
looks awful no power my foot's off oh my goodness
I was leaning forward which I felt totally felt that this was okay
okay I paused too hard there timing's out almost lost my balance
oh my gosh
there's so many mistakes I have to redo this I think I started breathing here
when I was counting right there but that's about it I was pretty much stopped
breathing one two my back legs not straight gosh I have a lot of commentary
ah complete mess of your narration um I think I get the weight